hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 12 of my road to one bill series
I'm a little bit sick today so we're
going to be taking this a little bit
slow uh we're going to start off the
episode by selling a bunch of items in
our bank some rars some Slayer drops uh
some air orbs uh some glories and we're
just going to try to get our cash deck
back up then we're going to start
tackling some quests uh we're going to
do the plague City quest line uh cuz we
did need to do underground pass
eventually we're going to do some
Diaries and we're going to do some
training all right let's get this stuff
sold and get the episode started okay so
we're going to start off with uh
actually run Mysteries which we have not
done yet uh pretty vital quest for a lot
of other things um but yeah we needed
room crafting eventually so we'll go
ahead and do it now okay so very quick
Quest we're finishing it up and uh room
crafting and one Quest point there we go
oh and an air Talisman okay so uh all
our stuff has sold so we collect it and
R up to 6 mil and now we're going to
start
um the plague City Quest um plague City
or the and the other one you know those
two um just so we have the uh
requirements for the easy Diaries uh for
our Dune as well as we'll need it for
underground pass all right got the great
off uh not a big deal there uh the gas
mask always kind of freaked me out a
little bit okay there's plague City
Quest done uh nice we get the ardun
teleport spell which is pretty sweet
as well as little 18 mining which
actually isn't too bad okay so the other
Quest is biohazard and we're trying to
teleport to ardun and I couldn't figure
out why but apparently we have to read a
scroll first before we can do it uh
there we go we have the ardun teleport
which is nice and we'll start The
Biohazard Quest wait a sec we got some
blue feathers coming in here so thank
you to making putts for giving me a 2.3k
feathers sweet okay so we're just about
to finish smuggling all the uh I don't
know what these would be qualified as
chemicals into H
farac and yeah we'll just finish up the
quest okay so we forgot the actual
poison on the ground cuz I kind of just
assumed that they wouldn't want you to
bring the poison in uh but apparently
that's fine so hopefully they stay on
the ground for at least like 10 or 15
seconds yeah that don't really make any
sense why would they let me bring the
poison in but not this other random herb
medicine potion thing all right there we
go we're just finishing up the quest um
not too bad I kind of like that one
actually and uh 1250 Steven experience
three Quest points and access to doing
the underr quest or underground pass
Quest as well as that was the final
requirement for the uh easy ardun
Diaries okay so another requirement for
the ardun easy diary is actually to get
a rusty sword so we came here to kill
ham members for a little bit and luckily
we got one pretty quickly okay and this
should be one of the last um tasks and
let just go to the ardun lever uh which
is not nearly as scary when you're not a
a hardcore Iron Man uh but anyway there
we go we can go claim our reward okay
there we go we have access to the ardun
cloak uh one as well as a antique lamp
which will give us 25 200 experience in
any skill uh so we're going to toss it
into
agility uh cuz agility is slow no matter
what you do pretty
much and yeah I'm kind of excited to
have this ardun cloak it'll be useful um
mostly when I want to go to like yanil
so we'll just do the teleport right now
boom put you right at the monastery
which is just a bit south of our Dune uh
which is pretty decent especially since
it's unlimited every day okay and the
first toxic blowpipe I'll ever own is
being bought um which I'm pretty excited
for I never used this item before so I
think what you need is Zar scales as
well as the type of darts you want to
use which I think we're going to go with
mithil darts cuz Adam and darts are
three times more
expensive and or maybe steel darts I
don't know we'll figure it out but we'll
go charge this up a little a little bit
and then go test it out okay so we're
setting up a dream for nightmare zone
for the first time ever I have no clue
what I'm doing right now um I've heard
you're supposed to do Rumble and I'll do
Rumble hard um but yeah maybe we should
look up a guide so it turns out I have
most of the quests that are required
except for Vampire Slayer which I never
ended up doing uh so that's fine I'll
just quickly uh stake this guy through
his heart and then we can continue on
with nightmare Zone all right there's 5K
attack experience and three Quest points
okay so we're in Nightmare zone for the
first time uh the quests I've done
are fight Arena Grand Tree trome Village
and Vampire Slayer um those ones are the
ones I've done that provide monsters for
nightmare zone for gear I have a guthix
miter F dehy uh stink skin boots a toxic
blowpipe an AIS accumulator and that's
it uh the miter just for prayer bonus I
think I guess that's what you want uh so
we'll see how this goes we're just going
to pop on protect from Meely and start
attacking uh we don't have um overload
potions yet cuz we had no points yet
built up uh but yeah we'll see how this
goes and see what experience we end up
getting so we ended up getting about 60k
an hour without overloads and about 80
with overloads wow that's a lot of blue
feathers oh thank you uh Med level Noob
for over one 100K feathers my god um
yeah no it's pretty decent experience
rates I didn't really end up losing much
I definitely going to go back there I
just really wanted to test out the
blowpipe uh but for now we want to be
training our Mage up but man I just want
to use that blowpipe okay so we finally
finished combining the majority of those
compost potions into Super compost that
was a bit of grind over the last week
but we are done uh we have a bit left to
just combine for super compost for
farming
we leave those and do them as we need
them we also finished another uh RAR run
up which and will get us another four or
500k in
profit and yeah we're going to sell this
off and then buy some supplies to do air
orbs okay so we are buying 2500 more
unpowered orbs and
7500 Cosmic runes so hopefully we did
the math right and it'll add up
perfectly to 3,000 I did not oh it's
pretty close though but yeah uh if you
didn't realize that is for 3,000 orbs
and we'll combine those into air orbs
and uh make some Bay okay so the compost
have sold and uh we need to buy some
more rard seeds for some more Farm runs
they are getting a lot more expensive uh
still totally worth doing I mean that's
still 700 800k in profit but uh it's
shrinking down a little bit all right
look at this guys I am alen why while
I'm charging air orbs uh not too bad
actually we just hit 69 magic as well
all I'm doing is bringing like some
items to Al while I'm running there I
can do about 20 on the way and it gives
me about 60k experience an hour as
opposed to 35 from just charging air
orbs so I don't know look at that
efficiency okay so we're about to hit
another magic level just from charging
air orbs uh we're about halfway through
the orbs now I think um but there's a
ton of PS here I haven't successfully
actually die to them uh cuz they never
actually stun you you just teleport away
but there's like tons up here there's
like a big clan battle going on below
which I try to get on film recording
whatever uh but I didn't manage to do it
but anyway there is level 70 magic only
five more levels for the Trident and as
part of eventually doing underground
pass as well as the uh lumbridge medium
Diaries we will need to go thieving up
and it's just kind of useful in general
okay there is level 20 thieving now um
we have to continue stealing cakes all
right we're just about to finish up
level 25 thieving this guy over here is
still face tanking the guard which I'm
not sure if that's just a bot or some
nice guy but anyway thanks either way
there's 25 thieving and now we can go
pickpocket uh Warriors so it turns out
we can only the warrior woman uh which
is not too bad but it's kind not really
sure if I'm getting better experience
here cuz they punch you in the face
quite a bit all right well I have my
right click off now or on turned on so
this is way easier um here's a level 30
thieving which is pretty nice and now
we're going to go ahead and probably do
the uh Feud quest for the next uh seven
thieving levels all right so we're
starting uh the feud Quest um pretty
easy to do realistically this guy always
tries to sell you something no matter
what you do when you talk to him but I
already bought all the stuff so we'll
get the quest started and uh the main
reason I'm doing it again is for the
15,000 thiing experience which will get
me right to 37 well you might not be
able to hear it but I'm playing this
snake a freaking sick tune and I never
actually knew this but if you play the
snake charm you can actually uh play a a
song uh so we'll see if we can get the
audio in here for that uh special
occasion all right there we go the quest
is completed uh 500 coins you get
actually as well as well as the 15K thie
experience and access to the Black Jacks
which will be pretty useful if I ever
want to seriously train my thieving
which I do not uh but there we go 15K
thieving experience and that should get
us right to level uh 37 thieving all
right and we just need one more level
for the uh lumbridge medium Diaries and
thieving silk which is way easier than
cakes to be honest but there's 38 uh
thieving uh we can pick pocket Master
Farmers when we want uh but we'll
probably leave that for now okay so
we're starting off another requirement
for the medium Lum Diaries and again the
reason I'm doing this is uh because we
want access to the Explorer Ring 2 which
will let us teleport to the uh F or
farming patch three times a day which
will be super useful it just kind of
getes us a break from magic
training okay and why we're at the
Museum is we need to get our hunter up
and we just finished all the little
tasks here and it actually gets you to
level 9 Hunter and since Hunter is so
slow in the beginning it's pretty
recommended to do this right away but
there we go nine Hunter catching these
things is just so slow uh so we're just
catching some copper longtails that got
us to 11 and now we're going to move
over to uh Cilan Twitches which actually
drops the blue feathers which is kind of
nice all right guys that's pretty much
going to be it for today uh we're just
about to hit 19 Hunter and we're going
to finish up the lumber jimy Diaries in
the next episode as well as trainer
magic up and uh probably do some more
quests so I hope you guys enjoyed the
episode and I will see you guys in
episode
[Music]